all right
welcome everybody uh come join in i'll
wait for people to start filtering in
i see paul pulia's here good to see you
i'm mike slender there's a lot of folks
coming in
all right yeah
and let's sort of sit here semi
awkwardly as people filter in
we get people in the door and
welcome everybody hope everyone has a
good first day of december
the year is almost over i think we could
all be excited about that
i think most people would agree we're
ready for 2020 to be done
yeah all right a bunch of people coming
in i'm going to just slip over here get
my slice of pizza
all right and we'll see as everyone's in
i'll start my announcements in a little
bit
um hello hey noam well you have to be
here you're our sponsor
hi ken good to see you again let's see
who
they see his names but if i don't call
it your name is because i don't see your
name pop up necessarily and also i don't
you know
call it just so i can't call it
everybody's name comes here we'd be
sitting here all night just calling out
names
all right um okay
so we will slowly get started the
announcements
as you know some more people trickle in
all right
so first things first we always like to
start the meetups with a question of who
is hiring
for obvious reasons we can't have
everyone offered jobs like we
normally do when we're in person i guess
normally we've been doing this for like
six seven months now so um
maybe normals you know the old normal we
had people just shout out jobs
so because we can't do that please join
the slack team and i'm not i think you
could have posted a link to the slack
team that slacked him in the chat
there is a channel called job postings
post your job there
i know that we've had a few and over the
past 10 plus years we've gotten lots of
people jobs from in person
but now we're getting people's jobs just
through that slack channel so it's a
zero cost way of trying to hire people
and um just let's get more and more
people job so please go in there and
post your job so again we will hopefully
be able to do that again in person but
we're hoping for all that to be in
person
all right next up i hope everyone has
their pizza i know we can't be in person
this has been delivered a little bit we
have cheese lock which is a good sign
see the bottom it looks like it's it's
uniformly charged no charm mark so
if i had to bet this would be in a gas
oven this is from a place called new
world pizza this time
um will you've been to a few of our
meetups you know that we are obsessed
with i'm obsessed with pizza
and we have pizza every month until the
pandemic we had a pizza poll
and by the way folks the data is still
freely available
it's all at gerrylander.com data pizza
poll
dot php something like that and it's a
json feed it's well it was live and now
we have live polls anymore
and some people have used it tidy
tuesday used it and thomas levine made a
painting of the data
so feel free to go use that data folks
uh so big week this week this is our
second r week of the year
we had the new york the virtual new york
r conference uh
last back in august so this year we
normally would be having a
washington dc conference we thought
since we can't be in person we can be
anywhere
it is an r in government and public
sector conference
it is anything involving policy and
governance
we have speakers from nasa from air
combat command from inquitel
the new york city department of mental
health and hygiene the new york city
council the census bureau the bureau of
labor statistics i could go on and on
and we recently added i'm very excited
we added uh graciela cincininski
she is an economist who was one of the
key authors in the kyoto protocol
i was very excited she was my professor
back in grad school so i emailed her hey
do you want to come give a talk about a
policy conference
so i'm super excited i took i was
excited i took that class of her 10
years ago but i'm definitely excited
that she's coming to come speak
um so yeah so we're excited for this
conference um the workshops start
tomorrow in the workshops we have three
workshops
causal inference which is so hot these
days um that's with lucy and malcolm
we have mapping for policy with kaz and
we have
machine learning for policy of john i'm
not saying anybody's last names but you
can go to the website to find their last
names
if you want to attend the conference or
the workshops use the meetup code
any events we put on it's for this
meetup it grew out of this meetup ny
hack r
is your 20 discount code it works on any
event you know we put on
and i think we promoted a python event
recently it might have already taken
place with james powell
there was a discount code there we
always try to give you discount codes i
think the python event already took
place
this past week i hope some of you
attended hope it was awesome i wish i
could have attended i love james powell
i just couldn't make it too busy running
up to this conference
um the way this will work since we can't
ask questions in person as we're all
aware
uh ask the questions either in the chat
window here
or in the slack meetup there is an event
called december 1st meetup
sorry a channel called december 1st
meetup if you go in there you can
post your question at the end of the
talk
i will go through the questions and ask
them i will and will will hopefully
answer all those questions and not dodge
any of them i'm just kidding we don't
have any speakers really dodge
um thank you to ecohealth alliance and
noam and emma
for uh providing the zoom for us uh it
is very helpful having them provide the
zoom every month it really makes this
thing
really makes this thing work um we do
have the next three months
starting to be planned out for the
meetups we will announce those
after the conference um so sometime
hopefully next week we'll give an
announcement about that
we actually are scheduling months in
advance now so if you want to give a
talk
send us an email and we'll tell you okay
you have six months to go
or it might tell you hey you need to go
next month both have happened right now
you have a buffer but both have happened
in the past
so i think that is all the announcements
i have just to remember
jobs post and job postings ask your
questions in the meetup channel called
december 1st meetup roughly called that
join the conference the next this week
if you're uh if you're feeling that
thank you golf alliance and i'll see
everyone afterwards hopefully we'll get
to see you again
in person soon but until then i'll enjoy
uh doing these virtual meetups
with that a few months ago
we had a talk from miles mcbain talking
about the drake package
and during that talk the author will
was there and i saw his name like he
asked a question like hey
you're going to give the talk of the
meetup and he politely agreed and here
he is to talk about targets
which is the follow-up to the drake
package and i'm super excited
so i just learned drake so i'm excited
to learn a new thing now so everyone
please give us a virtual round of
applause he won't be able to hear
please welcome will thank you will well
thank you jared
and ameda for organizing this and to eco
health alliance for the
for the infrastructure this is an
incredible meetup
with uh not only a large audience but a
great group of people
and and uh sorts of really thoughtful
questions i
i enjoyed the last couple of talks i've
i've attended here
so i'm excited to present that i'm gonna
try and share my screen it may take a
couple of tries and zoom
can everyone see in here yes
wonderful so
so today i'm going to talk about targets
and
like jared mentioned it's the it's the
successor to drake
originally i was i i knew this had to be
developed
after you know a couple years of of
secretly sort of
mulling this over and i mean comments
like jared's are
great because it just affirms that the
our community is is
incredibly open to and excited about
change
and and about growth and this is this is
hopefully a a little way to to
contribute to that
and um it just it makes it
super exciting to to offer improvements
and
and um to solve problems that we're
dealing with and
and to attack them creatively so
i come from the life sciences and we
develop ambitious
computational workflows for statistics
and data science
so there's a lot of machine learning and
bayesian data analysis
and simulation and prediction and
other domains have similar kinds of
workflows and we need to think about
both
efficiency and reproducibility right
from the get-go
and many of these projects have long run
times methods like
markov chain monte carlo and deep neural
nets are computationally
expensive and it could take hours or
even days just to fit a single model
that's fine if you're only going to run
the project once or at
regularly scheduled times as in an
airflow
setting but if the code is still under
development
and you still need serious results it's
easy to get trapped in a vicious
system cycle so a large project has
a large number of moving parts we have
data sets that we
preprocess or simulate or just procure
their analyses of those data sets and
and summaries and and plots and tables
etc
and if you change any of these
components whether it's a bug fix or a
tweaks in the model or some new data
then everything that depends on it is no
longer valid
and you need to rerun the computation
to bring the results back up to date and
it's seriously frustrating when you're
in development and you're still
making a constant stream of changes to
code and data in real time
so if every change means you need to
rerun the entire project from start to
finish
there's just no way the results can keep
up unless
you use something like a pipeline tool
and they're pipeline tools for
production which resemble
apache airflow and their pipeline tools
which resemble a new make
and i'm going to focus on the latter
today the make like tools just because
i think they're more they're they're
better designed
to skip artifacts and computation that
are already up to date and make this
sort of
iteration that i described a bit easier
um
whether you're in the airflow space or
the which which
solves a slightly different but equally
valid set of problems
um whether you're in the airflow space
or the make-like space
both are action-packed and there are a
lot of there are a lot of amazing
options out there
historically though there hasn't been a
whole lot for r
and that's where targets comes in so
targets is a make like
pipeline tool that's fundamentally
designed for r
so you can call it from an r session it
supports a clean idiomatic
function-oriented style of programming
it abstracts
artifacts as our objects you don't need
to work with it
the output files directly in most cases
and most importantly gets you out of the
system loop
of long computation it enhances
reproducibility
and it takes a lot of the frustration
out of data science
so let's go to an example at this point
i often
sometimes i i pick a machine learning
example that i borrowed from folks at
our studio
sometimes i i pick a simulation example
there is
um at a conference region recently at uh
at our pharma i talked about a covid19
clinical trial simulation example it was
close to my own work
but here i'm i'm taking a little bit of
a turn to
to make this particular presentation a
bit more unified because i have a
i have an announcement uh at the very
end um and this is
this is going to lead up to that so
we're we're going to take a bayesian
model that you see here and we are going
to
try to check that we implemented it
correctly
so i'm going to try not to assume
knowledge of bayesian statistics but
just know that this is a statistical
model
it's going to be implemented in a
probabilistic programming language
called stan
and we're going to validate this thing
and that means
we're doing is we have a workflow
and and not all validation workflows
happen like this
this is just one way we could we could
validate the implementation of this
model
we're we're going to develop a pipeline
where we simulate
a thousand data sets from this model
thousand random data sets
we're going to fit the the model to each
of these
data sets this model you see here and
this is where it gets a little bit
esoteric we're going to check the
the output of the model against the
parameters that we use to generate the
data
and and see if we can recapture the
truth behind the simulation
um and for for those of you who are who
are bayesians out there
we're just going to we're going to
calculate the 95
credible interval on this on this beta
slope parameter
and we're gonna we're gonna we're gonna
we're gonna count how many times the the
estimated credible intervals and all the
simulations
cover the true value of beta from the
data
and that coverage rate should be close
to the nominal value of 90
if the if if the model was was
implemented correctly
and there are other ways like i said to
validate models i found this one to be
to be quite good it's caught errors in
the past
and we're going to use stan like i said
it's a it's
it's a black box mcmc probabilistic
programming language
super popular i've been using it more
and more and i can say i'm an extremely
satisfied customer here and this is
how we would write the the model and
stan
um this is just the it's it's pretty
natural
most of the time and this is going to
exist as a
file in our in our workspace when we
when we set up the project
we're going to also need to write some
some custom functions to make this
this work happen so targets is very
function oriented and that's
that is intentional um it's
we are we're using functions because
they're
they they scale well and if you if you
have a large code base and an ambitious
project
it's natural for r so r borrows a lot of
elements from a functional programming
and it fits the paradigm of data
analysis in general so data analysis you
can think of as
a as a series of transformations from
data to
model objects from model objects to to
summaries and things like that
and it just fits the paradigm so well
and in terms of of tracking um
outputs and changes to to targets
it's functions just make this all come
together all
and and all possible um and i know it's
it's sometimes um it's sometimes maybe
difficult for those of you who are used
to
script-based workflows like our markdown
documents for
for most things or the or the the the
uh slug based paradigm where you have uh
numbers to to index your your imperative
scripts
like say one dash data dot r two dash
model dot r and so on um
we're going to try to get away from that
from for the purposes of of targets
because
uh it's it's it because of because of
the issues i described
and functions once you get used to them
can be a tool to help you
they they don't they they may be
intimidating at first but really all
they are is a way to express one of
those data transformations
um in in a workflow so most of the
functions that we're going to write are
either
um or fall into one of three categories
so number one
a function to generate the data like the
one that you see here
um another class of functions is a
function to fit a model
uh like this one where where you take
the data and in this case the model file
and you you fit the model and you return
some sort of fitted output
um and that's that's sort of another
major class of function and another
you might write some more functions to
generate um to generate summaries
like like plots and reports and even
deploy
outputs to say our studio connect or
something
and yeah those can be split up into
different functions but those are
the main three reasons why you would
write a function in a data analysis
workflow
including these these utilities which
support the the
main functions um
where and once you write these functions
you would put them you'd organize them
into files
any way you want but this is this is the
way i like to do it and this
this this tends to be sort of good
practice for
for you know maintaining a hygienic
workflow so
i'm defining a folder called r and this
is where i put the scripts where my
functions live
and you'll notice this for those of you
package developers out there this looks
kind of like a package where
we define a bunch of functions in a
folder called r and some people
do like to write packages i'm working on
making targets a little bit more
amenable to uh to to
packages as sort of one-off workflows
and
i actually broke through today and and
and solved something that made
the a technical problem that may make it
they make this practice a lot easier
but you don't need to go that far you
don't need to actually develop a package
for your for your workflow
what we're really after is a research
compendium just at
a a repository with all your code
such that if you give it to somebody
else and they run it they could
reproduce the same results that you have
um and and they could read and
understand not only
your your output but the process that
led you to get there
and that's that's part of what a
research compendium does
um ben marwick has written extensively
about this and he maintains
uh tools around this so i recommend you
you check that out for
for best for best practices of general
how you set
up up these kinds of projects because as
miles mcbain said in his talk
um drake and targets and tools like them
don't really
have an opinion about how you set up
your your project structure and that's
deliberate they're
they're they're tackling an entirely
different set of problems
um and and i think the research
compendium paradigm
tackles those tackles those problems
the thing that's specific to targets
itself is this underscore
file everything else looks like a
regular research compendium or
however you want to organize it but this
targets.file is special
so it's a configuration file that is
required
and it needs to be at the root of your
project and your working directory when
you actually run the computation and
most helper utility functions
and this is what it looks like so this
target star our file it's going to begin
by
by loading the packages that you need to
define
your your pipeline at a high level it
loads your functions and other global
objects
it sets options and it
um this could these could be global
options in r
or target specific options like the
packages that the
targets themselves need to actually run
the workflow
you don't need to use this packages
setting necessarily
but it does end up making a lot of
things faster if you do
the alternative is just to skip this and
write regular library calls for all
these things up top
and then so that's the top of targets.r
the bottom of this is where you define a
pipeline object
all targets dot our files must end in a
pipeline object which should be a call
to
tar pipeline and for those of you
who have used drake out there this is
kind of like your drake plan
and for those of you who've used make
this is kind of like a make file
and for those of you don't who aren't
familiar with any of these that's
totally fine
this end of of the target start our file
is is an outline of the high level steps
of the analysis
and each high level step of the analysis
is called a target
each target has a name like model file
here
it has a command and r which which gets
run not right away but this this get
this part gets delayed
but um this code gets gets written in
here and
quoted plus a bunch of other settings
but at minimum you
you have you have a name and you have a
command
all wrapped into this a call to this tar
target function which returns
a target option object which which goes
into this pipeline
and each of the steps of the analysis is
going to have one of these targets
so there's a target for the stand file
this is a compilation step
and here is is another step to to
simulate the data
and each when we go to the the model
fitting steps they will also be targets
and we're only going to add a few
targets to start out with
so what i recommend highly recommend
when you start
a pipeline is not to throw everything in
all at once
but just to just to get a couple of
targets going inspect your workflow
run them and then and then
add rinse and repeat you can you can do
this iteration because of how
targets manages the computation it
doesn't actually end up being that
expensive
and this gradual process helps make sure
things don't get out of hand
so once you define this target starter
file you can you can immediately inspect
it
and make sure that you've set up
everything correctly because um
you don't necessarily want to commit to
a super large computation
unless you know that things are going to
flow properly so
this graph is actually it's not
interactive in the slides but it is
interactive in real life you can click
and drag and zoom
these nodes and you can get a sense of
how things are connected
so this this data continuous target is
connected to
index sim and index batch and i'll
explain a little bit of that
about a bit later on but but the reasons
why
why these why these uh targets are
connected and the way they are
uh this data continuous target needs the
uh in this case an index to
to label sort of the the batched
computations that that i've set up
and and the number of um
and another index target here with with
simulations within a batch
and um because we're simulating a lot of
data sets
and we we want to group them
strategically into manageable
manageable collections here but the
point is that this data continuous
target depends on these upstream targets
and this is automatically detected it
doesn't matter the order that you write
that you specify the targets
what's going on is that is that this
data continuous target mentions the
symbols index sim
and index batch in various uh in various
places the the command
and then this uh dynamic branching
command um down here
and as well as this simulate data
continuous function and
what's what's nice is that it targets
automatically crawls through all that
and and and automatically detects that
that that the index targets um are
dependencies of this data target
um things in this graph should generally
be connected
so that so that targets um so the
so that your targets proceed in the
correct order likewise this model file
target depends on a bunch of functions
it depends on this
compile model function which depends on
this utility function called quiet
because compile model is mentioned here
and that's a custom function to just
compile the stand model
it's it's a little wrapper and
that is automatically detected here and
those dependency relationships are
important because
because targets is going to
automatically detect
changes to them and automatically and
strategically
rerun only what needs to rerun and skip
things that are
that are um already up to date which
saves a lot of time in in the case of
bayesian data analysis
so um after we're satisfied that we've
set things up correctly we can actually
run the the workflow
and this is going to use that graph that
that i mentioned so what's happening
here
is this this tar make function is
proceeding through the graph
running the correct targets in the
correct order so it's running a target
called batch index it's
running a target called model file and
then it's running
these uh these these data targets that
depend on
on some previous steps and
at the end of the day if if you rerun
the pipeline again after that's all done
and nothing has has changed then it's
going to skip these targets because
they're already up to date
now you may have a workflow where this
matters because and
in some cases it may be expensive to
simulate that data from a model maybe
maybe um the simulation procedure itself
is time consuming and
and skipping these steps saves you
several hours of or
or even just a few minutes of time and
if you're developing code really fast
that's
that's it's extremely helpful um we can
check the graph again
to make sure and and other utilities
like it to make sure that now
our targets are up to date so we know
what we're going to get in advance
when we before we run the pipeline again
at this point we can we can read our
our output so we can we can read
individual data sets with tar read or
tar load we can we can pull any
any target we want from the cache
because a target is associated with a
return value that's stored in
a it's stored in uh locally in a folder
called
underscore targets and those those files
live there they're going to be in your
project
and but you don't have to think about
those actual files where they live or
what they're called you just need to
know the target names
and this makes it super easy to do
exploratory data analysis
you know the exploratory data analysis
is something i get asked about a lot and
with these pipeline tools because
because a lot of this is is is rigidly
structured
formal pipelines um and and it doesn't
it it seems like everything's automated
but
is we have this we have exploratory data
analysis too because of how easy it is
to retrieve the results
this is much better than just than than
trying to
manually organize files it gives you a
lot of convenience and peace of mind
and at this point if we're if we check
the results we we experiment with them a
little bit we're satisfied that we've
gotten
reasonable answers we can move on we can
add
we can add some more targets we can
actually start to fit this model
which is going to say for each data set
that we've simulated
we are going to um we are we are going
to take this batch
of of data sets and we are going to
simulate um we're going to fit a
our a continuous covariate version of
this model to each one um
and if we after we add that to the
pipeline and we visualize the graph
again
we we see we see a couple of good things
here we see that first of all
this fit continuous function is is
connected to the upstream targets and
functions
and uh like like it should be and
it's um the the data and and the model
file
and also it's the only target that's out
of date right now
because we left everything else the same
we didn't change anything but we have
this new target now
and so when we run tar make again we
only run the models and we skip
everything upstream
um that that because it's already up to
date in this particular case
now tar make cluster and q is is a new
one
so i i chose this because in this
particular case
these targets were pretty inexpensive
and could run
locally just fine but and when i when i
ran this in scaled up fashion these
models actually took quite a bit of time
even though
i mean even though this is a very simple
model
mcmc takes a long time there's
there there is especially
even if even if it only takes you know a
minute or so
to validate a model like this in in the
in the approach that we're doing it
we're simulating and
we're running a thousand different
models a thousand or this model a
thousand different
times um and that adds up to uh
about 45 minutes in this case and so i
i went on my work's uh sun grid engine
cluster
and i i set some options in the
underscore targets.r file to connect
to cluster mq to the sun grid engine
cluster
i i selected a number of workers and
um and and these are going to be this is
d and and when i called tar make cluster
and q
a bunch of targets these these model
fitting targets ran in parallel on
different nodes of this
of this super computer and it got the
the runtime down to about
three ish minutes and
when i read let's at this point let's
let's go around the loop again let's
inspect the results
and we see that we've got what we want
we've we have um
a bunch of of uh summaries for each of
the models that we fit some summary
statistics on the posterior samples
and for for um bayesian modeling
workflows in general i would recommend
actually
um if you're if you're only running the
uh a a small handful of models it can be
fine to save
all those posterior samples but if
you're running the model thousands of
times i recommend just saving
compact summaries like these
these posterior summary statistics
and uh convergence diagnostics etc
and it's a bit a bit friendlier on on
storage that way
um and if we can visualize the graph
for this to like like we did before um
i'm just
showing this here to say that we the
graph can show a bit more information
than just
what's up to date and what's connected
to what so we have
um things that are stored in the
metadata that you can report like the
number of
branches here you can you can say well
how collectively
what was the um how what was the size of
this data and
um and how long did things take to run
as you can see yeah
we're about 44-ish minutes uh
collective total run time um but if i
were if if this were to fall out of date
again
i i would consider uh running this in
parallel on a cluster
or or on on the across the um the cpus
of a local machine if i didn't have one
so we can continue to add targets to to
the pipeline so suppose i want to
perform the same exercise on a set of
simulated data where the where the
covariate is
is discrete so i add a custom function
and
uh let's say we also want to add in our
markdown report that depends on
the upstream targets and the pipeline so
here's a here's another markdown report
that i put together
it uses functions tar load and tar read
to to refer to targets in the pipeline
um and so you can run so as long as you
have a completed pipeline
you can actually run this report by
clicking the knit
button in the rstudio ide like you would
normally
and that will just that that'll produce
the report but not only that
there is this tar render function that
is part of the extension package
tarkotypes which which is sort of a
companion to targets for
situations like this all you do is
supply a name and the report file
and other options that get passed to the
render function in our markdown
and this report automatically depends
on upstream targets that you've referred
to in the report itself
and so when when upstream targets
are invalidated this will this report
step will react to
so you get the best of both worlds here
with our markdown you get
you get integration with a pipeline
dependency
dependence on upstream targets and you
get the the interactive
um you you get to to
run it interactively so you can edit it
like you like you would normally
um edit a document i will say though
that that our markdown reports
are are best served as as components
of a of of large pipelines um
you can run a large pipeline inside our
markdown report you can call
uh targets itself from our markdown but
our markdown and and knitter aren't
really they're they're designed to solve
a completely different set of problems
and um they're i i
um i would recommend against using them
as
workflow managers for really large
projects they're
they're great for small stuff they're
great for um
they're great for tutorials they're
great for summarizing results that are
already computed
but they i think they should do as
little computation as
as possible and just serve to annotate
and summarize and explain
and display uh results that are already
computed in a pipeline
and um also i'll say it's
it's it's a really good habit to to um
to produce uh some kind of literate
programming report
as an artifact of the pipeline or or
multiple reports depending on what
you're doing
even just to keep track of of what
you've done
and what the project is about and what
all these targets mean
i recently returned to a drake project
that
i needed to present on you know the the
next day but i hadn't touched in about
six months
and it was really complicated a lot of
custom code
this this weird simulation workflow that
i hadn't ever done before
um so there are a lot of there are a lot
of things that were they were a bit
rough around the edges but i looked at
the report at the very end
and you knew exactly what the targets
meant and
and not only that everything was up to
date so
um not only did i know exactly what to
go in and change
uh to to add to add that answer this
sort of little question that i got asked
from from a colleague but
but also also um the computation time to
make that happen
was really short because because nothing
had changed since then and
you know i i was there was no way i was
gonna remember
what happened six months ago but drake
did and was able to to salvage a lot of
that work
um but anyway uh when you when you run
this it'll
again run the correct targets in the
correct order make the decision to skip
targets that are already up to date and
so it'll run this report last because it
depends on
all the modeling work that we've
previously done up to up to this point
and so our pipeline at this point is
completely built up built up but you
know of course things change right so
you go back and you change a function
based on based on you know new ideas you
may have since you've last ran it
and targets will automatically detect
changes in this function
in functions like this functions in your
in your environment
so we're making a change to simulate
data discrete function
and this is going targets is going to
notice that this changed
and because this function changed so did
the data and then the model
is put into question and so is the
report
and again it's going to automatically
run those those targets and only those
targets
and sure enough when we when we inspect
this report
we see that um it does answer our
original question so we're not getting
we've we've been in the implementation
side so far but we haven't strayed from
the
the original problem at hand our
coverage rates
coverage rate in this in this case is
about 91 percent
which is is is just above nominal so
that's evidence in favor of of this
model being implemented correctly
um and likewise we can include plots of
posterior estimates
against the truth and uh diagnostics and
so forth
um so at this point with the completed
pipeline it's it's nice to check that
everything is up to date again
because this is this is tangible
evidence of reproducibility at this
point you might
you might step back and reflect on your
work and reflect that things are up to
date
and this this sort of claim that
everything is
that the output is synchronized with the
upstream code and data
that's saying that somebody else could
could run this same
code and produce the same results that
that is the statement that this is
making which is
is central to to the the whole the whole
concept of
of reproducibility certainly not the
only thing reproducibility means
reproducibility is a
general umbrella that encapsulates what
it what it means to
to trust a data analysis project or the
or any of the the the software stack
behind it and even the the scientific
methodology behind it
um but but this is using a pipeline
toolkit for large computation
that gives you this kind of evidence is
is
part of that and it's a and it's a
really important part of that
so at this point um i'll say that
targets is
under review by our open side which is
super exciting we've we've got reviewers
in there
um and and they're they
um i'm excited to see what they say
they're um they
they're people who i i have a lot a lot
of respect for and
and they're i'm just and i'm really
curious to hear what they have to say
and
it's going to make the the package a
whole lot better
because of the potential for change
during that review process i've been
delaying
uh submitting it to cran but you can
install it from github
uh it's it's in a it's open source you
can stall
install it from this this repository
with this command and there's a
there's a lot of documentation that you
can use to uh to learn about it so
this workflow exists in a um
in in a repository of its own so does
this
the so do these slides and the slide
deck that i'm that i'm showing you right
now is at this url
there's an a half day uh short course
which i
which i taught at our pharma and plan to
to teach repeatedly
and there's um there's a there's a user
manual with
with some in-depth uh discussions about
features and then there's a reference
website with all the the functions laid
out for you
and sort of a high level um listing of
of the external uh documentation in
various places
and just to show you uh one one of the
resources is actually
an r studio cloud workspace so if you go
to the the repo
that um that that this example
is is a part of you'll you'll see this
link um
i seem to have lost the uh the the
zooms green box that confirms that i'm
that i'm presenting can everyone see a
github repo
in um on your screen right now
yes fantastic great um this is why i
should use zoom every day instead of
microsoft teams
so um so this
the workflow that i described is in this
github repo here there are instructions
about how to
how to deploy it what do these files
mean how to access how to run it on a
cluster
and there's if you go to this rstudio
cloud workspace you will get
you will get a a you will automatically
be pulled into
to an instance of rstudio server where
you can run this code for yourself
without having to install
any any dependencies on your on your own
all
all the packages and all the files will
already be there
i know it's it's having a little bit of
a delay refreshing right now i
thought i'd pulled it up in preparation
for this but um
there it goes yeah so you'll you'll get
you'll get an
instance of rstudio ide and you'll be
able to you have this pipeline
you have targets and you'll be able to
run what i ran
and showed you today without needing to
install anything locally
likewise for the short course
so the short course goes through
interactive exercises
and teaches you systematically about the
the concepts
involved in targets it takes about a
half a day
to teach it you start with the machine
learning pipeline and you gradually
build it build it up
starting with the functions and then the
pipeline then you build up the concepts
to more advanced features
um and and get deeper into this into
this machine learning pipeline
um and you're you're hopefully left with
an
understanding of the of the concepts
after this i plan to teach
several more iterations of of this at um
going going forward
but there's nothing stopping you from
taking it yourself it similarly has
another rstudio cloud workspace and all
you need is a free account to be able to
access it
so at this point i will go to some live
coding
um so a lot of questions a lot of times
i get asked the question well how does
this all interact with with shiny what
um how how does shiny interact with
these automated pipelines um
and i'll say that there there are a
couple different families of use cases
that that i've seen
number one is to have a targets pipeline
inside
the um the uh inside a shiny app
which and i've and i've colleagues who
have done that um
at work and there's another use case
that allows you to automatically deploy
a target
at the end of a um at the at the end of
a workflow so
um you might might see um
so i've i've actually modified the
pipeline for today
to automatically produce a
a shiny app to display the results of
the mcmc
so instead of instead of showing a lot
of static plots it might be nice to show
um summaries of the
an interactive collection of plots in a
dashboard
to say okay do i want to show the
results for the continuous or the
discrete version of this model or
this in terms of the covariate and do i
want to see
uh means or posterior medians as my as
my summary statistics here
if you if you scale up the number of
plots it might be it might be
cumbersome in a report but in a shiny
app we can we get it all in one view
and so i've added i've added targets to
the pipeline
to make this happen and so this this
pipeline this graph here
show that yeah so here we've we've got
this
this target to to deploy this app here
on the left at the end
sort of over and above in addition to
our report
so what i'm doing to make this happen is
i'm
exporting these results to to a file
in this results file target and i have
this special
export results function that i wrote and
all it does is just save an external
file
this export results returns to the path
of that file
and format equals file into our target
just says okay
treat the res the the return value this
command as a character string denoting
the path to the output file
and then for future reference hash this
file and track it for changes
so you can invalidate targets at the
right times
next we have a target to similarly track
the
the source file of the app and another
to call the rs connect package
to deploy the app to rstudio connect and
so to
look at that deployment function all
it's doing is is using this
this very magical deploy app function
and it's going to take the files it
needs and it's going to
force update to shinyapps.io
and one thing i notice right here is
is the first time i deploy this this app
there's there's something
that i already want to change so there's
this awkward white space here
um because of this this sidebar on the
left
is is is missing i didn't supply a value
and i didn't take it away either
and i want to make more use of real
estate here especially because i'm
taking up half the screen here
to show you all um so what i'm going to
do is i'm going to go into this app.our
file
and i'm going to say aha i need my
sidebar and i want it to be disabled
so i'm going to uncomment these lines
this
this is a change to a file that we've
tracked with this
uh format equal to file keyword here
this this option
in this appsource target and when i
check the pipeline
now to see what's up to date what i'm
going to get
is some outdated targets so this app
source is out of date
and so this deploy target is called into
question here
and what's going to happen is when i run
the pipeline again
it's only going to focus on those
targets that are in light blue here
so let's run tar make and by the way
don't forget that these upstream targets
are super expensive these are
these are mcmc targets
we have 40 batches of of 25 simulations
each of this of this workflow and so i
really don't want to be running those
again especially
because i'm live coding here i want this
to to get to the deploy step right away
and if i do this this uh tar make that's
exactly what it's going to do
so it's skipping all these targets these
fit discrete targets
took a long time it goes straight to the
deployment step
and this is going to take a little bit
of time but it's
it's it's a very good use of time
because it's exactly what needs to be
done
to synchronize the output with the with
the underlying
um the underlying code
so this could probably take um
about a minute and and while this is
going i think i might be able to take a
question or two
all right so we've got a few questions
um already
um one is do you always write a function
for each target
or do you sometimes just write a quick
expression therefore using a deep higher
pipeline like
select a mutate would you just put that
right in the target
so that's a great question i think it's
it's good practice to condense
down the commands that you actually put
in the pipeline
even small d plier pipe chains can get
can get pretty cumbersome if you
insert them here you can do it it's just
going to get a little bit more difficult
to read and maintain
so i i like to write to write compact
function calls based on either custom
functions or just
really short calls here um to
to make sure that i can go back and and
have this tar pipeline call be pretty
short
um
i'm going to do a follow-up for this
person does ever get burned so i'm like
oh i seem to write like call two
functions and i have to do it so you go
to put in all the time to write a
function i guess for you that's not a
burden i guess right
well um i think you know it's i'm for
for somebody like me who's used to
writing functions that may not be so
burdensome but i understand
the the desire to reduce the the size of
the code base or if you're not
comfortable writing functions
you don't you don't have to to write um
as many as i've written here
so i've written a bunch of utilities
here to
to do nice things to like silence some
of the output
and save results to file but you can
you can you can certainly put these as
as just
inline expressions in um
in in these in these commands um
especially as you're getting used to
function oriented
a more function-oriented style of
programming
and i think whoever came to uh miles's
talk a few months ago he actually wrote
an rstudio plug-in to create the
function for you maybe
it'll be a target's version of that yeah
so he's been he's been talking about
that i'm not sure what
hit the decision his group is is going
to be but um
they've certainly uh talked about um
he has a package called d flow which
which which is
it's a bunch of really nice stuff over
and on top of drake to make
to make to make it just much easier to
define and document functions just
magically really easy um this is exactly
the sort of the sort of thing that
that we've the sort of magic that i
would expect from the author
the author of of of data pasta um
it's it's it's quite magical um but i
think
a lot of this whether using targets or
drake or not
or or neither um the same principles
apply
and and so i think that that he's going
to be able to reuse a lot of his
previous work for this
good good um and i'll just uh at this
point i'll say that our pipeline has
has completed and we have this updated
app
now remember previously we had this
awkward sidebar and it no longer exists
it's it's gone and so you can see that
um see how the you can see here the the
effects of of running this pipeline
just um and the aspect ratio of this
plot is much nicer
on on half a screen um and once again
if i run tar make again having changed
nothing everything's already up to date
and so that's that's the the um
so that's how targets itself works um
at this point i'm going to finish up the
formal part of my presentation by
addressing drake so i've talked a lot
about targets and i've said it's the
successor to drake
um you know like i said i was originally
nervous about releasing targets because
it's it's asking a lot of the community
to switch
to switch tooling um it's never
something that i
i i do lightly um
and you know that drake is
is the it's it's a it's the most widely
used thing i've ever developed
and um and it takes and it takes a lot
of effort to just to be able to
to um to get on to get on board with it
um but there are there are good reasons
why
i've i've created targets there's just
there is
um by uh over the years
as i've as i've noticed um as i've
noticed inefficiencies
come to light and notice users struggle
and be surprised in certain ways
[Music]
initially i i kind of rolled with that
and and made up for it and documentation
and tried to help people
get work around those problems but i
mean eventually
over four years of development we got to
the point where
drake's um most pressing problems
were its unsolvable ones so there are
permanent things that i just can't
address in the infrastructure
because it's it's either too fundamental
to the design or too fundamental to
um people's existing workflows that rely
on features being the way they are
um so and and not only that i've i just
learned to be a better and this is not a
reason why i did that but
at the same time concomitantly i learned
to be sort of a better developer and
and i've i've confronted um
a use case where object-oriented
programming and design patterns were
i mean there were there was an actual um
reasons that sort of i came to
understand to solve more of the
to see more of the problems they were
intended to solve um
all this came together in a in a higher
quality tool
so targets has stronger guard rails
and it's it's got lighter friendlier
data management
a bunch of improvements to dynamic
branching um
and extensibility in meta programming
and there's a there's a statement of
need with a bunch of these
a couple of things that i'm not covering
here are its ability to debug
stuff much more easily there's a big
section in the manual about
about debugging pipelines and targets
and
that's that's already a whole lot easier
and it's something that just
that that wouldn't have been as possible
in drake um
i'm i'm also trying to make targets
easier to to use with
custom packages as workflows and
tracking changes in
in functions inside packages that a user
the user develops um that feature isn't
quite there yet but it's another one of
those things that wouldn't have been
possible
in in drake that i'm i'm almost there at
and implementing um let's go some of
some through some of these main
advantages so um
stronger guard rails so drake is is
a bit flexible so it it um
it it allows you to define different
kinds of caches in different kinds of
locations
but with targets pretty much the only
way to use it is the correct
way it always does the work in the fresh
clean reproducible r process to avoid
detritus and the working direct in in
the in your environment
it's paternalistic about the working
directory and the data storage
and it removes flexibility that that has
tripped people up more than it has
helped um
it just leads to a smoother experience
and as it was take as i was telling
jared before the official presentation
um the data store is all is is lighter
so drake's cache is is quite large with
a lot of
bookkeeping files and it's really hard
to put this thing under version control
or or recover when a file breaks
um a lot of this is not only it's not
only cumbersome and difficult to read
but also
but also if if one of these files is
corrupted it's very hard to recover
but targets simplifies a bunch of this
it it has the
only the it the number of file scales
is the number of of targets plus two
and it's only the the metadata here
targets meta meta is sacred other files
can break
and and and the next run of the pipeline
will just recover this automatically
the folders are the files are a lot
smaller and so that you can ship this to
for sm for small projects you can even
put it on github
um for larger projects you might want to
to look at something else like uh
like google drive or or dropbox
but the synchronization process proceeds
a lot faster
and on top of that integration with aws
s3 is seamless you can declare
an s3 bucket and targets will
automatically ship the data
to that bucket and track it and
by the way reading data and exploratory
data analysis
fashion also connects to the cloud in
the same way and so
and so interacting with cloud data uh
also feels
just like interacting with with local
data um
cloud computing is another story uh
we've we've got the the cloud storage
part solved i believe but cloud
computing is going to take a take a
little bit because of where where
our itself is in in this space
um and i've i've got some conversations
going in the open source community about
how we're going to do this
um introspection is much improved as
well so
so targets can can tell you
not only which targets are out of date
but also which functions are out of date
so it'll
it'll allow you to to sort of look at an
out of date workflow
and and better understand about what
changed since you last ran it
drake does respond to changes and
functions but it can't tell you as much
about why
about which functions changed so this
feature in targets makes it a lot easier
to
to sort of uh it reduces frustration and
increases transparency and reproduce
stability
dynamic branching is a lot better so
dynamic branching means that you
that in a pipeline you define new
targets based on the values of previous
targets so you're you're
you're creating new targets as the
pipeline is running
and you actually saw some dynamic
branching today in the
in the um bayesian data analysis
pipeline
um but dynamic branching it's it's a lot
more flexible now
so what you can actually do in this as
demonstrated by this code is you can
actually use dynamic branching
to loop over subsets of of a
of a data frame where those subsets are
defined by d flyer group by
so you can define a grouped data frame
and use the the tar group function to
define the groups
and then every downstream target that
branches over it will automatically
create a
one branch for each group of rows um
this
people have been asking for this in
drake since the very beginning and it's
finally possible thanks to this clean
slate and
and the learnings that we've taken from
drake um
parallel efficiency and dynamic
branching is a lot better this is
this is the the most difficult but most
rewarding
potentially part of well one of one of
the
rewarding parts about about targets um
so drake had this
had this parallelism um
workflow that you that you see here
where if target b
maps over target a in a dynamic
branching fashion
there are these finalization steps in
between um
so so this this produces a situation
in drake where where you have to
wait for all the the branches of an
upstream target to start any of the
branches of a downstream target
in targets you're not limited to this
mapreduce
efficiency constraints you can proceed
to the next steps
the next branches even if some upstream
branches
still still have work to do
and this this reduces uh this increases
efficiency and reduces runtime it's more
responsible with resources
dynamic branching patterns can be
composed so
you can um you you can
for example in in this example pipeline
you can
you can create a new branch for every
combination of w and pair x and y
and you can create sort of arbitrary
arbitrary dynamic branching patterns
this way
which which just which allows you to
just select the targets you need without
a whole lot of uh messy workarounds
um and
lastly but last but not least there is
meta programming opportunities because
targets um
isn't limited to the domain specific
language of drake plan
that drake was limited to so there there
were features
in drake that that assumed that you were
only going to use
only going to define workflow flows
through the drake plan function
and targets tries to tries to be more
open
and say well there's and and define um
and and it lets you define targets
outside of a pipeline statement so you
can define target objects on their own
and then put them together in a pipeline
later which is something you could do in
drake
and they're ways to define targets
without
any standard of without any um
non-standard evaluation so
this this tar target raw function makes
it really easy to program
on top of um on top of things in targets
and it opens the door for extensions
like target types which you saw
are markdown report integration that's
that's exactly what makes this possible
here in
a very clean um maintainable way
and here is where um
i have i have a little announcement to
make i have a brand new package
called stand targets which is another
one of these extensions made possible
by the the extensibility and meta
programming capabilities of targets
and let me let me pull this up right now
so stan targets
is is an extension to the cmd stan r
package and targets itself and it makes
it super easy to maintain to
to set up um stand based pipelines
um and relative to this example today
you saw
a bunch of targets and a lot of code
maybe you didn't maybe you
saw you know pattern equals this for
dynamic branching and thought what's
that
uh may have been confusing and
intimidating but
if you're if you're doing bayesian data
analysis like mcmc or variational bays
or even optimization then stand targets
can help you
get get the exact benefits of of targets
that i described
but with minimal custom code you don't
have to think about these advanced
branching features you can just
uh get the targets you want and skip
expensive computation
um and this
this this package is on github i
released it
literally yesterday it just got approval
to do so um you can install it from
github
um and just to give you a flavor of
what's of what's possible here
um this this uh simulation study
is is pretty much the the vignette that
i
that i describe here a very similar
model with a very similar pipeline
now instead of this this long this long
pipeline that i showed you earlier
it condenses down to just this
so to give you an idea of the pipeline i
had before
it's uh it was about 80 lines and you
had to worry about
formats and branching and settings and
stuff
over here you just you just need this
and most of these arguments are specific
to to stan
um so you you give it a model file you
give it a data generating function
and you just use this specialized
function in and stand targets to say
okay i want to do a simulation study
with these these number of batches in
this number of reps
and and in this case i want to produce
these summaries
for for the the validation study that i
described
you automatically you you have one what
looks like
a call for one target but you actually
get several targets
pretty much the targets you had that
that that i described in the main talk
and um this automatically gives you this
this validation study and again and
and just a couple lines of
post-processing you have
um this this nominal coverage that tells
you something about the correctness of
of the implementation
of your model um so it's
this this is gonna i i think i hope
that this will be a game changer in
specialized uh
pipelines like this um you also have
a function here to to just take a single
model
and maybe this is a big model that runs
for a long time
and and just run it once with a tar
stand
mcmc target and you you again call this
small
very condensed very simple pipeline
statement and you immediately get five
targets which
which are are there six targets in this
case so you have the model file you have
the mcmc
object that's completely serialized and
retrievable and you have
example sampler diagnostics and the
actual draws of your mcmc which you can
customize
and summaries that you can customize and
you get all this automatically
with minimal minimal custom code all you
need is
is again a a function or or to to
generate the data or a symbol that is
just the data object
and the model file you don't need you
really don't need to think about custom
code here you get all the benefits of
targets um
so that's out there now and i i think
and i hope that this sets a precedent
for other methodology specific packages
i mean there could be
a targets extension just for machine
learning or targets extension
just for you know either whether it be
keras or
torch or tidy models um or
you know other other kinds of of of
specific methodologies
i've colleagues who've written
extensions for this for
specific for for sort of simulation
studies in the life sciences
uh the the possibilities to make this
this sort of thing
uh convenient is really exciting because
all this time the major limitation of
all this is is the burden on on
on users to write their own functions
and to write their own custom code
but if we have sort of pipeline toolkits
that are specialized that extend targets
to
specific methodology where all this is
already figured out
there's really not much for that that
the user uh
can be intimidated by um so i am
really excited about where this is going
and hope to take it further next year
and with that i'll open up the the rest
of of the
of the time to questions
thank you very much for that excellent
talk i think if we all could be here
we would give you a virtual applause i
will applause for everyone hope that my
little golf clap
is enough in that microphone server to
be very happy about this
so uh thank you very much for that talk
and i would sit here and tell you thank
you again but we need to dive right into
the questions
so first up um
so there's a question why not call
rs connect deploy app directly why have
a wrapper function around it
um that's a well it's just a stylistic
choice again it's
it goes back to the to the first
question um why do i define this special
deploy app function
and it's just it's just style otherwise
otherwise this this underscore
targets.our file could get quite large
and the star pipeline call could get
quite large um
to split things up and and and make this
this short is
is uh usually is usually something i end
up thanking myself for doing
all right and then in a similar
similarly related question
i'm not going in order they came in
because some things seem to bunch
together
uh what's the best practice you've found
for maintaining all these functions in
like a well-documented way
for using for using targets do you like
document your functions using oxygen
what are you doing
yeah so i do use oxygen comments it's
very natural to have
to have the usual oxygen tags that you
see here that i'm displaying
along with along with even some examples
to to run them that are self-contained
um i collaborate with drake based uh and
and hopefully in the future target space
simulation projects
uh many of which were covered 19 related
and and fast paced and it really helps
to have examples of these functions um
in line because i'm not always writing
the one writing the code i'm
collaborating with my colleagues a lot
and i need to understand how their
functions run because i'm contributing
to the to their to their pipelines
and sometimes i'm reviewing them for for
internal validation purposes
so i think that the most important parts
of these are the the examples
that should be self-contained and the um
explanations of what the parameters mean
especially if you're if you're
collaborating with with colleagues and
have a tight timeline
okay yeah so oxygen has been a blessing
um so along those lines
there's a question here
um but what was tar script versus the
tar plan
oh yeah tar script just uh just writes a
a target start our file automatically so
what what i can do is um we just open up
a terminal here
and and uh
yeah i didn't i didn't mean to actually
focus on tar script because it was a
little bit of an unnecessary distraction
for persistent projects but
just for the sake of getting things set
up easily tar
script writes um just writes code
automatically to an underscore
targets.org file so for example you
could say
our pipeline our target
and that would automatically write a
um
that would that automatically writes
this targets.file here
the the function that i think is a bit
more useful here is actually
um let me close out some of these files
just to make it
more more apparent so there is this
function called tar
edit which automatically defines a
target start our file if it doesn't
already exist and it opens it up
in the rstudio ide and this
this this is actually so tar script is
is mainly to help people who write
documentation and produce
reproducible examples to share in bug
reports but
uh tar edit is is for for
what people are going to be using most
most often to access this file
and then uh since i'm not sure if miles
is here will that also work in
vs code i'm not sure i would definitely
have to divert to miles on that one
all right challenge through gauntlet
thrown down to miles if he's not here
all right um then we have a question
about um actually i can answer that one
that you
that you asked to the extent that use
this edit file
um uses uh vs code which i don't think
it does because it uses the rstudio id
api it looks like um but to the extent
that use this edit file
works in vs code that will that that
could work in vs code as well
and i know someone um the person charger
via the vs code are
our package or whatever i'm not sure
what they call i think they call
packages maybe
did talk about something about how they
can replicate the rstudio api a lot in
vs code i remember seeing a tweet
but i don't remember exactly so that
would be cool
all right um this is not a question but
a comment
i just wrote a simulation based
calibration for a stand model this
morning this package looks fantastic
so kudos you could have solved this
problem you gave the talk yesterday you
could have solved this problem
glad to hear it i'm sorry it was a
little bit too late
yep that hopefully it'll be helpful
going forward for it for him
um then the two questions actually i'll
condense them into
one um no no if they are separate
yeah i guess they're related a is there
a
like some sort of a oh i'll just do the
second one does targets have functions
to transition from a
drake workflow into targets um not
explicitly to automatically make the
transition
uh but there i've i've tried to help
with where that's concerned so there is
documentation on how to do this
so if you go to the um
sorry uh this is my personal website
but um if you go to
oh maybe it's in the manual actually let
me go to that
so at the beginning of the manual
there's this what about drake section in
the first chapter
and it turns out that if you if you know
if you know
drake you almost already know targets
and so
you can do is you can go to this table
and you can see how the
the drake functions that you use map to
their counterparts in targets
and it's and it's the the mapping is
mostly very smooth so you have functions
and you not only have that you have
you have arguments to to make and see
how they
map to arguments and targets and you
have
optional drake plan setting which which
much mapped to optional target settings
um the the other thing that i'll say
here
is that um i i took miles advice
about uh and his comment about that that
not everything in targets is is easier
than drake and
and archetypes i i actually um
actually created this this function
called called tar plan
and archetypes to make to make uh usage
um a lot easier so we go to um
we just if we just pretend this is a new
pipeline file
um we could do something like uh tar
pipeline
tar target x simulate
and then another see
data
so we have a pipeline here and this is
actually equivalent to
something that you would ordinarily see
in drake where you have
a more intuitive assignment if you have
custom settings you'll have to fall back
to tar target and you won't be able to
do this assignment within tar plan but
tar plan for for a lot of use cases
does does have the ability to define
pipelines in a very drake
like way which make which and and miles
has used this
and and reported that it's that it's a
lot easier to to transition
um and you can even combine very
different parts
of different different pipelines if if
some
if some of your pipelines need settings
like format equals
fst ubl would to make
custom compression to speed up the
process and lighten the load um
if you have different pipelines that
some
if not everything you can do into our
plan if you have to use tire pipeline
for
for some things um you can actually uh
put this put this stuff in here
um but there are ways to to actually
uh combine
uh
there are actually ways to to combine
these these pipelines together
um so uh maybe that
last bit was a bit off topic but uh i've
i've tried to make it the transition as
easy as possible in spite of the manual
work that's required
i actually like this this turning to a
personal question of mine i know i
talked to you about this on github
um and the last day said it wasn't
really facebook i have some projects
we'll have like five different drake
pipelines going
separately but together they sort of
sometimes they feed off each other other
times they're isolated
it almost seems like if i separate them
like this it allows me to keep that
that separation yeah and you can even
define you can divide these up into
different files
you don't need this monolithic tar
pipeline call i only put it here because
i didn't want to avoid introducing too
much but you can do things like
you like i said define these in
different files you can even define
lists of target objects on their own so
do something like this and
and you can even have multiple lists of
targets
um this this is this is equivalent to
what i showed before
uh except for the syntax error
oh there we go yeah
so uh these are target objects and
they're they're just uh
there's there's a lot of of uh
structure but i guess as you can see um
a a target object is just a fancy
environment with a bunch of data inside
um so this so these objects exist on
their own outside of
any domain specific language um so you
can treat them as such
and you can you can supply arbitrarily
nested lists to
tar pipeline nice that will be very
helpful you sign up for my use case
hopefully for other people's
all right cool i'm that that's actually
i'm very excited for that so i'm not
saying that i uh
one of the issues i talked to about
months ago so i'm that makes me very
very happy to see this
good and related to that a question just
came in
um is there a way to and there's more
questions by this one just came in about
that so i'm going a little out of order
because it seems like a nice follow-up
is there a way to use a variable to
determine which targets run
say if you want to stream for morning
versus afternoon
oh that's a good question so you can
programmatically configure the pipeline
to
to do this you can have um you can
programmatically put the
pipeline together like i showed and
there's there's really nothing stopping
you from
from selecting targets in this list uh
targets also support something called
cues which are kind of like drake
triggers um
see this this cue here you define
through the the tar
q function and you can you can select um
if it always runs or never runs unless
it's missing or and and a bunch of of
things you can select
to to determine there's a decision rules
to determine whether to run it
and on top of that there is a a
tar change archetype in the tarkotypes
package
and this one this allows you to define
some code
that sort of that determine that that
that's going to always run it's this is
going to be this is going to turn into a
target that always runs
um and it's going to be upstream of the
main target
and this could be something like
checking is it morning or is it
afternoon
um so and so tar change makes makes
arbitrary queues a little bit easier
okay so the guitar sounds like tar
change might be the one
this person was looking for um then we
have an
earlier question which sort of ties in
there how would you
schedule this targets plan to run on a
daily or hourly basis because like you
know before we had this
video call i i talked to you about um
connect could schedule things but if
you're not using connect to kickoff
targets how do you schedule targets are
using
what do you use so this is not something
i often
encounter um i may in the future based
on
some projects that are coming up but you
know outside of
of something that looks or acts like
cron
i'm not exactly sure i mean targets
itself doesn't have
doesn't exist on a timer that runs at a
specific schedule
i think that's something that airflow
tools are more or more interested in
tackling
but it's but but on the other hand
there's certainly nothing stopping you
from from setting up something like like
uh like a cron job to automatically
um run um a targets pipeline on the hour
every hour or or
or something to that effect uh i i think
that targets itself will play nicely
with those
with those scenarios and and tools that
that accomplish this
elsewhere in the art community will will
also accomplish that this here
okay so stuff outside of the
any scheduling service that you would
like yeah yeah
okay which you know cron has been around
for a while for a reason there are
packages for cron
um if you don't want to use crown itself
there's actually there's an r package
for linux cron is in our package for
windows equivalent
which is cool all right so then
um what if you have
a shiny if you had a shiny example
earlier earlier i'm guessing i know you
had shiny i'm guessing that's why the
question was asked
the shiny app depends on data that could
change
while the app is running and you want to
run that data through a target's
pipeline
how would you do that since the example
you showed had targets deploy
shiny how would you you know have shiny
use targets yeah so
is this a question about the data
dependencies
of of the kind of shiny up deployment
workflow i had or is it more of a
question
of i have a shiny app that runs
a a target's workflow and how do i and
how do i make that happen
from the wording of this i am going to
guess that
you know the you get data in and i'm
guessing that
has to go through a series of steps
before it's ready to be shown by
shiny but it's like data that changes is
what it seems like
versus data that would be static each
time you deploy like
you're hosting this thing and next week
the data changes
but you know yeah yeah so i think this
pipeline
attempts to solve uh that problem so
um if i if i'm understanding correctly
we want the app to be deployed when the
data changes right
and so that's what this this target does
this results file it it takes
it takes the the results of the mcmc it
externalizes it
and it tracks it as a file and this is
actually the
dependency of of our of our app
and so before before we ran this um so
this results file is a dependency of
this deploy step and so when this file
changes that's going to invalidate the
deploy step
and it's going to trigger another
deployment to our studio connect
i think they're asking the other way
around i'm reading into the question now
though so i'm not sure
yeah but maybe people were asking what
you asked but i think they're saying
like i know some people they have like a
shiny app that reads from a database and
each time you click go right it reads
from the database again we shouldn't
have to go through a series of steps
i'm guessing what they're asking so yeah
so this sounds like a situation where
you'd have a
potentially a pipeline inside the shiny
app that may have an expensive
computation
on sort of it no when when the user
clicks a button
it checks that it checks the data and if
the data is changes
changing it it does some some expensive
processing or something
it seems like this that could be use
case that's that
if you if you if the app has access to a
file system a persistent file system
to uh to to maintain the
the the the target that the output files
the targets generates
um it seems like it seems like it can be
handled that way
my one of my colleagues built a kova 19
simulation
app um and uh
he did a similar thing with with drake
actually
um so it's the those sorts of things are
that are possible it is a large
undertaking because
because of the the session management
and file system management that has to
happen inside the app
but it is being done okay all right so
hopefully that answers the question
um then someone actually they just got a
comment in referring to
something you just talked about earlier
was i often use tar change
for targets oh and i've used tar change
change ecosyst.date
for targets that should be updated every
day
i've used that markdown so
yeah that sounds like it'll that sounds
like it'll work
nice um i assume do you still have time
to keep answering a few more questions
absolutely i've got a light all right
well wonderful we're gonna say crack
open a beer let's do this
um someone is asking um
can these targets be stored and
documented and tested within our
packages
oh that's a good question so i i'd
actually um
and i get asked about automated testing
within a
context of pipelines quite a bit and i
would say that um
it can it's it can be a good idea to
maintain the code behind an analysis
in a package if that's your style you
can do that i'm working on making the
the tracking of changes and those
functions bit easier
um but uh as far as testing goes i think
that should
that test should happen on just like in
a package scenario where you have
you have scaled down tests that are that
are targeted to
very very limited examples for functions
as sort of built-in unit tests
so you know tests are great they they
catch regressions
um to old bugs and they um
they they should be used as often as
possible but they shouldn't necessarily
be computationally expensive
and that's that's where some of the
difficulty comes in here because these
pipelines are computationally expensive
and sometimes especially for the
bayesian validation study i described
you may have to run this quite often in
order to
in order in order to to actually um
to be actually to actually be able to
tell whether whether your results are
are believable
and are correct we spent this entire
simulation study
just to check the nominal coverage of a
parameter
so but i would say the unit tests
themselves
are are should be independent of the
pipeline on individual functions
and then the the pipeline itself could
it could be a form of of test or or
validation of a method that you put
together
um so but there's there's
i think there's so there's nothing
stopping you from writing writing tests
that unit tests either in the
either in a test that folder in the in
the
workflow itself in the pipeline itself
or in
a separate package where you've
implemented uh most of
most of the content of the research um
but just to keep the the tests the unit
tests as as sort of
both conceptually and physically
separate from the pipeline
is is a strategy that that i've i've
come to recommend
okay yeah so like they say the same
thing as shiny
uh you know right turn out make
everything as much of a package as
possible so that's easy to test
and keep that out of the shiny logic
exactly
they're they're they they're different
things that solve different problems
that work
very well together uh when when both
pieces are
are are physically independent but
supporting the same goal
i like that i just think we know when i
write a lot of my
package tests it's like oh here's a
function that takes the input of this
other function from the package
but that's a one maybe two hops only
charge is probably overkill for that
anyway
and i can imagine just what crayon would
do when you set up a test that's going
to run for an hour you know oh my gosh
yeah that that's the sort of thing we
want to avoid but tests are run
early and often and so we want to make
them light on the we want to be nice to
the infrastructure that the crane
maintainers have been
have been generous enough to to afford
to package developers like us
oh yeah they have to get compute time
somewhere they have servers that some
a lot of work with crane does yeah yeah
um so here's uh
actually so this actually there is a
these are sort of related ones a comment
so i'll do these
so question well first i think noam
actually answered
the miles's function mate works great
with both drake and targets so that's
nice to hear
so that's good and that steps into the
next question
do you think we ever get to a point in
our where we can target
targets if i and arbitrary r script by a
static code inspection and beyond
so i guess you get an r script and it
creates targets oh my gosh
that that is a dream isn't it yeah uh to
to
pro to uh through static code analysis
uh crawl through a script and turn that
into functions
um i would love to see that i i haven't
personally
decided to solve that problem but there
there is actually an r open psi package
called rclean
that does something similar where it
you'd identify
an artifact that's produced somewhere in
this on this
long complicated script and it
it goes through the static code analysis
necessary to just return the lines that
are
that are important to to only that
object
uh and and this this helps it's more for
a readability thing
um and and just and and to to aid
refactoring as
as well if that's something that users
are motivated to do but
i it seems like if that were possible we
would
that's kind of what that would look like
and maybe it's an extension to arclean
maybe it's um it's something else but i
mean
similar users have tried similar things
um
in drake actually there was to sort of
ease the friction
of of moving from scripts to functions
ellis hughes
from fred hutch actually wrote an
extension to turn a script into a
into a a whole script into a function
that can be that that behaves uh
in such a way that that it integrates
nicely and safely in drake pipelines
um i've kind of resisted that for
targets itself
um because i i don't think so targets is
more about
paternalism than flexibility um and the
the the child proofing is is super
important and it's part of the the
intent
of of the package um and i know that
causes friction but i'm really hoping to
make up for that with packages like
stand targets
where you don't you barely even have to
write custom code
if you're if you're if if you don't have
many custom targets to add
after the the main automatically
implemented processing steps
i'm fine if you're making more work for
yourself so you know
yeah i i i you know the dream is to have
a
whole targetopia of interesting packages
gonna come with a checklist of other
obscure things you need to support now
yeah no it's all it's all good it's it
solves a problem i've i've been trying
to solve for years about about
about you know being able to help people
who
who clearly who clearly struggle with
the workflow
issues that target solves but but
don't really have the the activation
energy to to get over that
to get over that barrier to of to
adoption
um and i've actually this came from
from my colleagues um life sciences
specific simulation package
internally he wrote this really thin
layer on top of drake
um it's proprietary so i can't share it
but
but after four years of trying to get
people internally
to to use drake when they were
struggling with computation and
and just getting glazed looks back uh
this this really thin layer was
immediately adopted
and it was and i mean it's
it was it was amazing because it was it
was the same thing i've been trying to
do for years and
only required this this little push and
i'm trying to
withstand targets i'm just i'm just
trying to make this little push
in and methodology methodology specific
areas to to
um to reach people where they're where
they're at um
and and this is just the beginning
yes yeah so andrew gunman will be
speaking at the conference on thursday
so i think he'd appreciate seeing uh
the stan targets thing oh my gosh
so to have to have the eyes of somebody
like andrew gelman
just that would that would that's a big
deal
nice send me an email i'll
send it to him and we have uh jonah from
his team and rob tranguchi they taught
at workshop recently
recently back in april for uh for the
meetup
um so we're very the stand team is very
much loved in this community so and
they're very involved
so we'll get you definitely get some
hands-on for you with them awesome
yeah i've i've loved interacting with
them i've uh
i've i've been talking with with jonah
quite a bit about
uh about cmd stan r and he knows about
stan targets and
i'm i'm hoping that that we can uh
you know we can we can help each other
out going forward and uh
it's uh yeah i've i've enjoyed
collaborating
with with him and his team everyone
loves jonah all right everyone
yeah yeah he's so friendly yes
yes he is um and he's done uh so much
like
her my wife needed to stand for research
and i asked jonah to make a feature and
he made a brand new feature because she
needed in her research so he's awesome
yeah yeah all right so that's enough
founding over jonah we could phone over
um there was a follow-up to that
question about the static target oh
actually before i get to that person's
follow-up
um i'm throwing a challenge to you in
our studio does have a thing where you
can highlight a bunch of code and we'll
turn it into a function
have you seen this so it's theoretically
closed i know it's not even
connected to but it's close that's
interesting
and this is this is not part of function
mate this is
uh click code on your screen
uh okay um
extract function a little higher oh okay
and i have to highlight something right
highlight somebody write some art code
apply to be like sort of like a few
lines of our code and
extract function let's see if that works
yeah
ah that's really cool
yeah it just and identifies the global
variables here to produce the signature
i assume
yeah oh it's cool wow
yeah i i think that i might start
recommending that now
that is that is really cool yeah yeah
it's really handy
yeah it's it's exactly the sort of thing
miles would write did he write it
this has been our in our studio for
probably like a decade now
right wow old code such a wow
i would this is such an underrated
feature yep
yes wow yeah right yeah
so hopefully that'll get us closer to
that person's um
question let's see who asked that
question one day oh that was henrik ha
henrik asked that question um so now you
have to do it you've seen this hendrick
asked you have to do it
so what what uh to what what is there to
do it specifically is it
great to make a plan out of it oh right
yeah
i'll i'll think about that i'll keep
thinking about that no so
i i still believe in the in the strata
in the stand target strategy of
of reducing that the code that needs to
happen to begin with but
i i um yeah i
i i i understand the the push and it's
it's well taken and i'll i'll keep
thinking about it
and good because he had a follow-up
question and if that doesn't exist which
it will eventually it sounds like
challenge um what about generating a
skeleton from a script where most things
are filled out but not all
ah okay so like a like a function script
skeleton or a pipeline skeleton
yeah sort of like your plan thing you
have i guess right but more
more tailored i guess hmm yeah so
the the the interesting thing is that
it's it's a very general use so
i'm not exactly sure what what a what a
skeleton
would would need to look like here's the
the closest i've i've come
so if we have if we start r again and we
we i'm in a different working
directory than the the stand based
project so um if i
if i say tar script here um
with no with nothing with no code
supplied what it's going to do
is it's going to just
just populate an example workflow um
and which is which is pretty small and
pretty extensible
so um i i guess that's part of it
um but i i do i do kind of have trouble
wrapping my mind around something that
how do you establish the patterns of
something so general
uh it's it's easy if you you know the
goals of a specific pipeline or a
specific methodology
but um yeah i'd be open to to more ideas
about how to do that in the general case
oh just use gpt3 and have it do it for
it right oh
fair enough no no all right uh so you
know paul puglia jumped in here
um saying there's a rcvp.package got
skeleton and all these things are just
skeletons i think heinrich is trying to
get out like
a more tailored skill than just a
generic skeleton so
that's my guess you can like a more
in-depth one where it also sets up
functions
and uh template files for cluster and
things like that
but within reason yeah okay yeah
um i i yeah it's it's a it's definitely
a good idea and
my colleagues have have wanted something
like this for their their workflow
specific packages their life science
specific packages and
um yeah maybe
maybe maybe in two archetypes maybe uh i
i don't know i'll have to we'll have to
get get some discussion going and see
what with something like this would look
like
nice uh henrik just chimed in he has a
skeleton generator that tries to infer
as much as possible from a script and
that as much as possible is what becomes
what's realistic
okay so to infer as much as possible
from a script so it sounds like you
would you would have
you would already have some code to
start with yeah and
uh it seems like maybe
maybe parts of the script can be
automatically turned into functions
in the same way the ide does and how do
you choose which part
yeah that's hard but yeah so i mean if
you if you have an external light
a script file for an externalized our
markdown report that we have
comments for code chunks that may be a
little easier
but i i would uh it seems like it seems
like that
but but even that's very specific um
so i don't know it's sort of like how
there's an r markdown thing enough or
you could write an r script by putting a
special comment in it'll
treat it as if it were a chunk so if
someone went in like um decorated the
file that might be possible but you know
yeah sort of a decorated file would
would would
that that already opens up a lot of
possibilities
yeah all right so i'm gonna leave uh you
and henrik on github to go
and uh make something happen i'll give
you i'll give you two of you three
months and we'll jump
that's fair um that's why we do things
at this meetup um
i had a uh years ago michael kane
and jay emerson they had a like big
memory it didn't work on windows
so i said okay we're going to sit down
before the meetup we're not leaving
going to the bar
until we solve this for windows
but i very quickly saw that in the
package description it said
operating system unix only just delete
that line
oh it's like the the classic story about
how
how people first tried to solve all of
ai
right yeah
nice so another question we have for you
is does targets keep a history of
targets
eg a copy of the data for each iteration
change
that's a great question i'm happy you
brought that up because that's another
difference between drake and targets
so drake um drake is a bit of a pack rat
no
no pun intended uh it's uh it's
it's data store is i mean i don't
maintain that data store it's datastore
is
is actually designed to hold on to to
old data and detritus as long as you
don't garbage collect anything
and i actually use that to implement
history
not only history but also data recovery
uh
built into drake itself and it's sort of
made up for the lack of of
of sort of version control because of
how
how strange and complicated the file
system was for targets
i made the deliberate decision not to
implement any history or data recovery
um and the reason is i just i i don't
want to get into that
targets already does a lot i think it
should focus on just the problems that
it that it set out to solve
but what it does do is like i said it
lightens the
the the data store it makes the it makes
the whole system a lot more readable
the file names are informative there are
far fewer of them you can even put small
projects on git and github
and for larger projects potentially
dropbox or osf or
or or some other system the goal is to
make targets play really nicely with
third-party version systems
version control systems that that will
do a much better job than anything i
could ever implement
um so and i think that
based based on the uptake i think it's
succeeding in that uh
even if you you and and one of the best
parts is
if you if you use the aws integration
that i thought that i talked about
uh you basically get data versioning for
free because you can
it's super easy to turn on uh versioning
in an s3 bucket
um so you can you can you can do that
versioning already through through
amazon tools
great example that was a big thing in in
drake and i remember i was oh i've got
to delete my whole
thing here is taking too much space yeah
um there are ways there are functions to
garbage collect drake
uh caches but um
but often yeah often i found myself just
just deleting the whole thing or one a
filo's corrupted if i'm copying it
somewhere it's
because of the esoteric names it's hard
to to diagnose where that even comes
from and
it's another reason to delete the whole
thing but like i said targets caches can
just recover themselves
and if you as long as the metadata isn't
corrupted
yes because i definitely did rm-rf on
the drake cache a few times
yeah hopefully less now on targets yeah
yeah
less less less burning it all down um
then we have this is the last question i
have unless somebody sneaks in
um what would be your approach for
translating an existing project not a
drake project but like an existing
project
into a target's projects so i'm guessing
this is more like hey what's your
methodology your best practices like
do you have any like general purpose
recommendations i'm guessing that's what
they've asked
yeah so this goes back to hendrick's
suggestion about about
writing skeletons and automatically
converting
parts of scripts into functions and
this the the farther along you are in a
project that is not function oriented
the more difficult this transition is
going to be and it's
in if in even automated tools may not
solve that because
static code analysis can't predict the
return value of functions so
um and you got to make sure those
functions have
have sensible return values and minimal
side effects which
involve other programming decisions that
that
that can't really be automated so um
what i would
what i would do is i would i would take
a step back no matter what stage you're
at if you're committed to
to transitioning to a target's workflow
just i would take a second to think
about okay
what are what are my data sets what are
my analyses
what are my summaries and what is
what is a function that expresses each
of those steps and each
variation on those steps um what is
uh and inside this function how can i
how can i express that logic
in a way that that has a a
very defined set of inputs for for
arguments um
and a a a an understandable
easy to work with single return value uh
from that function um and and i would
just
that's that's that's always how i would
think about um
making that transition or or starting a
project from scratch
yeah yeah i like that it's like the
first time i used drake i had a 4000
line project and i
decided to translate all into drink code
and it was worth the effort
took a lot of effort but it was worth it
awesome and i'm glad to hear that and
the trade-off the trade-off is different
for different people
so um here's a little bit of an origin
story when i was in grad school i was
working with this
massive bayesian hierarchical model um
and and it was working working on
on a paper and a few papers
with it and this this thing would take
hours and hours uh up to
you know for the for the whole
dissertation it
the whole workflow took about a couple
weeks if we were running it to end to
end
and i implemented an our package to do
all that and it was clearly a situation
where i
where i should have been using the
available pipeline tools
um but i was just too far downstream
it was it was it was too it was too
developed
for me to to pivot that much and and
that's okay if you've already got a
workflow that works for you or you're
already or workflow is already too far
advanced
to be able to change easily then then
that's fine
you just you now you understand the
problems that that you encounter with
these large projects
and you you understand that the value of
pipeline tools and maybe your next
project uses one
um but my my advisor would always
jared neemi at iowa state was was always
telling me
um you know if you used make you could
solve a lot of these problems
you could skip computation it's already
up to date you would have these defined
steps here
um and make was was just hard to work
into what i was doing
and i took his his comment under
advisement but i didn't implement it
right then and i think
i credit his his initial advice and his
is you know concerned for the the
welfare of grad students and
and uh and and workflows in general
to to the fact that i became interested
in this area of development to begin
with
i mean there would with you know without
without that project and without his
his you know planting seeds there there
would be
there would be no drake and there would
be no targets there would probably be a
remake
uh but remake was this the predecessor
to
to drake uh by rich fitzjohn um
but uh but i wouldn't have gotten
involved and this is some of the most
gratifying and and rewarding and
and uh impactful
sets of things that i've worked on um so
and anyway that actually made me come up
with a question my own now
um so i don't mean to step on the toe
that is rewarding i'm very happy that's
been impactful and rewarding for you
um it's been rewarding for me using it
so i can tell you i'm sure it's been
rewarding for many many other people
using it too
i know we had i think amanda dobbin gave
a talk at our conference
i'm not sure it was last year this year
years starting flow together and she got
a whole talk about drake we've had other
talks about drake and um
i've seen other meetups do it so i could
tell you that
it's been impactful for a lot of people
i'm really happy to hear that
um this is one of those ideas that's so
strange and
and unfamiliar and i mean
because of where i was coming from i
could immediately see the value
um and but i guess you never know
and this is i i'm just really glad to
hear that
that uh you know people like yourself
and others have have
have uh benefit benefited from using
this that it makes data science easier
and smoother and
um and and more more reproducible and
more informative
yeah yeah it's i think a lot of people i
hear a lot of buzz about it
it's uh it's very exciting yeah and i i
have to say that
that the the interac the community
feedback that i've gotten
and is has been has
taught me a whole whole lot about what a
pipeline toolkit should do
if i were just working on this myself
then
then then it would be the results would
be unrecognizable i would have solved
you know
the the initial one or two problems
within a couple of months and then
and it would be totally unrecognizable
um
the the thousands and thousands of
comments have built up my own knowledge
and and raised the bar for what for what
a pipeline toolkit should be and i've
gosh it's it's unreal that the amount of
the amount of
that i that i've learned from from just
talking with with users along the way
um and i've tried to channel all the
i'll let this
past four years of learning into this
into this new ecosystem
nice yeah good that's what open source
is for as well yeah
um and so i hate to step on that
beautiful mode but i have my own
question to come up here
you compile stan and you can cache x
understand as a compilative
plus distorted memory so a and then
let's say talk about an rcvp function
that's not in a package but you compile
right as part of a target can you cache
those and just reload them without
having to
recompile that's a good question c
c plus plus code um compiling in memory
and storing the
the the the executable and memory that
gets tricky because
um yeah i i haven't done that personally
um isn't that a stand model though same
thing like when you compile it it's a
compilative plus plus program
yeah and that's one of the reasons i
actually chose to build on top of
cmd stan r rather than rstan because cmd
stan are
complete it doesn't use uh our the
memory system and r
it writes the executable directly and
it's it doesn't depend on what session
what our session you're in about
as far as the decision to recompile a
model or its ability to
to to use a pre-compiled model um our
stand does
does a lot of things that are that are
um you know with
with you know uses model objects and
memory in such a way that
that sometimes makes it hard to use um
that that i have struggled personally
with with pipeline tools
uh they use our stand um or pipeline
situations that use our standards
certainly possible i
you know in each time i've i've worked
out some
some issues and tried to try to avoid
sort of
session-dependent uh behaviors that our
stand
deliberately deliberately opts uh opt to
um but i think that
that whole um those kinds of objects in
general get tricky because
for the purposes of targets uh a target
is is an object that can be stored in it
to disk and then read later with no loss
of integrity
so to to serialize a compiled
uh objects
[Music]
can can you know get can get somewhat
tricky in that regard
um especially if you're if you're in a
distributed computing scenario where you
compile locally
and then you're you're using that
compiled model on a different
node of the supercomputer it can um i've
i've had
some strange things happen um and there
and
c plus plus code in general that's
compiled inline
um using using the tools like like rcpp
um i mean those those exp those
unexportable objects as henrik likes to
likes to call them
um can be can be troublesome with with
with targets um some some objects like
keras models and torch models
have special serialization functionality
built
right into into the package actually
um to make to make all that work because
those are very common use cases
um but for the the purposes of stan i've
just decided to go with
with cmd stan r okay that makes sense
that that's a good solution
cool so i think we've i've exhausted
everyone's questions
so i just like to end that for everyone
listening hey this is
open source at its best you know
willow cam wrote a package got thousands
of comments lots of github issues
and adapted them made a new package um i
think you know we've been running this
open statistical programming meetup for
yeah i think we're on 11 years now and
it's been a very beautiful group of
people amazing people who are very
smart and kind as let's all just keep
that going with open source let's ask
nice questions let's
ask new features let's contribute to
them and encourage these open source
authors to keep doing great stuff
um so thank you will for the talk thank
you for the packages
and contributing open source that way so
thank you very much uh thank you so much
for inviting me you have such a
high impact incredible group of the
people in this
meet up here it's been it's been super
exciting to be part of it
great i'm glad i'm glad there's a silver
lining that pandemic that
and we're going to try to continue this
once we go back into in person
uh we've been filming the the meetups
for a long time uh we tried live
streaming them in the past but audio
problems
we're gonna make an effort to fix our
audio problems this way we can have
these
live um for everyone during when we go
even when we go back to person because
we have people from all around the world
i know you're here you know henrik's
here i saw we have some other people
from
other other continents other cities in
america we really look forward to be
able to continue that and keep everyone
going because
why should we be geographically limited
right right
completely agree yeah so
thank you i know it's getting late you
are in the east coast time zone but i
don't know if we have some europeans
there
hanging in a bus um so thank you very
much i look forward to uh
seeing you around uh we have the
conference these next few days hopefully
as many people can join and hopefully
the next few months we'll see you
virtually at the uh
future meetups we have january february
march over those lined up we're planning
out the following months
and um thank you for coming and everyone
if we give a virtual round of applause
for will
i'll go for my microphone thank you very
much for attending it's not quite the
same as when we're